donc votre bloqué donc la réforme
j'imagine qu'elle va reprendre c'est
qu'il est sorti de la CNP mais je vais
revenir juste une chose sur ce qui vient
de se passer non mais répond
ez gestion est-ce que est-ce que vous
pensez que cette réforme peut à son
terme aller à son terme être promulgué
être appliqué dans le pays après ce
parcours très très chaotique ici au
Parlement 47 ans 44 3 votre bloqué au
Sénat 49,3 à l'Assemblée c'est sûr que
c'est pas les meilleurs circonstances
dans lesquelles il est passé et moins
qu'on puisse dire avec là je dis très
librement on n'a pas pu avoir le débat
ici à l'Assemblée nationale parce qu'il
y avait évidemment donc ça pose plus
globalement un problème de démocratie en
général on peut pas continuer de
fonctionner comme ça moi je vous dis
avec beaucoup de gravité il y a un
problème démocratique à utiliser le 49 3
sur cette réforme on utilise la
Constitution que chacun connaît depuis
58 quand François Mitterrand président
de la République après avoir écrit un
bouquin formidable accepter le coup
d'état permanent il a dit qu'il
changerait tout pour rien changer donc
en fait la première visite elle est
utilisé un outil et je regrette qu'elle
les fait je vous le dis claire on aurait
vu qui voter qui ne votait pas que les
républicains qui sont allés mettre dans
toutes leurs affiches pendant les
campagnes législatives et
présidentielles la traite à 64 65 ans à
67 fois certains vous voyez le problème
c'est imposable
que le sexe ne soit pas adopté les
malaises de certains qui sont dans la
rue on a mal communiqué cette forme
depuis le début il y a eu des erreurs de
communication des fois des sincérité il
y a aussi des vrais avancées moi je suis
battu pour expliquer qu'elles étaient
ces vraies avancées pendant le sol et
les femmes ce qui n'avait pas été repris
mes repris dans la réforme de 2015 du
Marisol Touraine qu'on a corrigé
partiellement sur les seniors c'est
peut-être pas un truc idéal que l'on a
fait mais au moins en essayant de faire
un nouveau contrat sinon fallait rien
faire donc on ne peut pas laisser comme
cela dériver ce système de retraite il
faut dire que le système de retraite par
répartition est menacé il faut dire
qu'il y a des déficits de considérables
alors on n'est pas mais vous n'avez pas
convaincu vous n'avez pas alors
aujourd'hui sur la méthode il y a eu des
erreurs
finalement pour cette réforme
avait nos esprits parce que moi je cru
jusqu'à la dernière seconde qu'on allait
pouvoir voter d'ailleurs je pense même
qu'on aurait pu gagner de quelques mois
bon telle n'est pas le cas maintenant
49-3 considère que c'est une brutalité
sur une réforme aussi fondatrice que
celle-là du coup ça veut dire quoi
ça cons
exécutif il appartient au gouvernement
de savoir si oui ou non il a la
possibilité de remettre les métiers sur
l'ouvrage de modifier cet homme de
choses on verra dans les semaines
prochaines ce qu'ils vont se passer la
franchise du moins d'abord j'ai des
différences avec lui dans le sens où il
y avait des vrais avancées dans cette
réforme elles sont incontestables par
exemple sur les carrières longues il y a
des jeunes qui actuellement qui ont
démarré avant 21 ans il le sait
parfaitement parce qu'il connaît très
bien le texte qui devait avec le texte
actuel cotisé 180 trimestres pour partir
à la retraite c'est la vérité avec ce
texte sa permettait de partir un peu
plus tôt j'ai expliqué les femmes j'ai
expliqué d'autres avancées mais ce que
je veux dire simplement y a-t-il une
alternative politique pour le moment en
France non parce qu'on voit bien que les
oppositions ne s'entendent pas les
insoumis ou du moins la nuit Pesse n'a
rien de commun avec le rassemblement
national sauf que de temps il mélange un
peu leur vote mais je leur fais pas le
procès et en tout cas ils voudront pas
s'entendre non plus avec les
républicains mais là où j'en veux au
Républicain c'est quand même un peu
étonné un peu surpris que certains
effets des calculs politiques pour ne
pas voter cette réforme en tout cas je
pense qu'il y a les républicains
aujourd'hui de ne pas avoir permis le
vote de cette réforme
n'étaient pas en possible en capacité
d'apporter suffisamment de suffrages
alors qu'ils ont faisaient beaucoup il y
a eu beaucoup de républicains qui ont
suivi leur responsabilité donc il n'y a
pas d'alternative politique ça c'est
vraiment la première chose qu'il faut
savoir donc moi j'appelle à une nouvelle
étape cette nouvelle étape et bien il
faut peut-être capable de construire une
plateforme de gouvernement avec des
sociaux-démocrates avec celles et ceux
qui se retrouvent dans une majorité de
projets parce que sinon dans 6 mois on
se retrouvera dans les mêmes conditions
bloquées sur un autre texte parce qu'il
y a une majorité relative les Français
nous ont demandé
un accord de gouvernement mais avec avec
qui les républicains a priori
normalement été suffisamment nombreux
pour vous permettre d'obtenir une
majorité absolue Jean-François Copé qui
depuis de longs mois expliquait quand
même pas on va pas se raconter une
histoire il y a pas beaucoup d'éléments
qui nous séparent avec les insoumis on a
des lignes mais ce sont des lignes
claires ce sont des lunes de position ce
que je c'est pas contre lui parce que je
fais partie de ceux avec lesquels on
débat pas souvent en accord mais
quelquefois d'accord mais tant mieux
l'exigence que nous vivons parce qu'il y
a ceux qui nous regardent il y a la rue
qui nous regarde il y a nos enfants qui
nous regardent ce système de retraite
qui est un joyau français extraordinaire
hérité de 45 rue de fragiliser à un
moment d'ailleurs où les communistes et
les centristes et certains républicains
se sont mis d'accord nous sommes devant
le même enjeu soit on est capable
ensemble du bâtir quelque chose de
solide soit ça sera un effondrement mais
s'il y a l'effondrement parce que ce à
quoi on a assisté tout à l'heure un
amphi non moi j'ai été président de la
Fédération des internes de France ça
c'était un emphys qu'on a vu là de
sortir les affichettes ça n'est pas
digne de l'Assemblée nationale de
chanter la marseillais après des
République rassemblement national qui se
lèvent non il faut pas faire ça
c'est quand même l'hymne national
la première ministre de la supprimer les
événements on la chiant dans des fêtes
mais je suis désolé l'hémicycle c'est un
endroit sacré c'est l'endroit de la
parole c'est l'endroit de l'É c'est
l'endroit du débat ça n'est pas
l'endroit du chahut contre la méthode
franchement il y a eu de la concertation
mais vous avez quand même utilisé le 47
ans qui obligeant 50 jours à débattre de
l'ensemble du texte une très fine
observatrice de la vie politique depuis
longtemps dans cette maison est-ce que
vous connaissez un autre texte sur
lequel il est autant d'amendement jamais
moi j'ai connu les réformes de retraite
j'ai connu celle de Bertrand je connais
celle de Eric verte j'ai connu celle de
Marisol Touraine jamais il y a eu autant
d'amendements qui ont été c'est une
bonne chose que je fasse beaucoup
d'amendements Philippe non
mais 137000 amende sur EDF il y a déjà
eu beaucoup plus d'amendements sur
d'autres réformes
j'ai pris l'exemple des retraites sur
lesquelles ces discussions ont eu lieu
du tout non non je suis prêt à regarder
le chiffre quand vous voulez et ils sont
tombés par paquet en tout cas je
revérifierai vous dire franchement que
là on a bien vu que c'est une stratégie
d'obstruction parce que il voulait quoi
qu'il arrive ne pas voter c'est à une
relèvement que d'ailleurs un peu une
hypocrisie parce que quand on voit ce
qui se passe vous savez très bien que le
départ moyen l'âge moyen c'est 63,annet
on est allé raconter à tous les Français
qui partiraient tous à 64 ans ce qui est
un mensonge il y en a 6 sur 10 vous
savez très ça a été redit par le
rapporteur général qui partiront à 64
ans il y a tout le régime spéciaux qui
reste pour certains en dehors des cinq
sans supprimer les autres restes il y a
les carrières super actives et des
carrières actives pour lesquelles vous
savez cela travailleront deux ans de
plus mais une partiront pas à 64 ans je
pense par exemple aux pompiers je pense
par exemple aux policiers je pense par
exemple à ceux qui travaillent dans
comme dans les centres de détention dans
les prisons donc les gardiens de prison
donc voilà alors maintenant c'est les
choses sont là il y a un 49-3 qui est
passé par là une fois depuis jeudi je le
regrette parce que vu tout ce travail
parlementaire et on sait qu'elle a
investi et je trouve que la Commission
d'expéritaire avait abouti c'était plus
texte du Gouvernement c'était un texte
singulièrement évolué personne n'est pas
le remettre en cause il y avait quelques
économies à la clé substantielle 10
milliards d'euros à l'échelle de 2030 ça
n'est pas rien la démographie est ce
qu'elle est rien clou et c'est très bien
qu'il y a un actif pour 0,9 retraités
dans la fonction publique comment on
fait pour payer demain tout le monde
demande plus de salaire tout le monde
demande plus de retraite et puis quels
sont les outils qu'on avait pour
financer moi j'avais fait au début vous
en souvenez probablement des ouvertures
est-ce qu'il faut augmenter le temps de
travail tout de suite la gauche m'a dit
surtout pas faut rien toucher c'est un
acquis social c'est un viole j'avais
proposé vous savez peut-être 30 minutes
de temps de travail en plus par semaine
ça a été balayé dans un verre de main
donc si on va pas chercher ces
financements haute par plus de travail
et
plus de richesses qui viennent parce que
justement demande aux Français de
travailler un peu plus longtemps on y
arrive pas parce que les petites
retraites elles vont continuer très
basses parce que les carrières hachées
continueront de souffrir comme on le
promet malgré les corrections que nous
avons à ce stade oui est-ce que demain
nous annoncez française aux Français
ouais ça peut être une annonce
officielle à 15h55 que vous êtes prêts à
faire un accord du gouvernement avec les
républicains avec Yot elle voulait pas
des rassemblement national j'ai bien
compris mais vous savez très bien que si
vous n'êtes pas avec eux vous n'avez pas
la majorité c'est vrai pas le
gouvernement c'est ça qui me pose une
vraie difficulté c'est pour ça de toute
façon censure il y aura pas de
renversement du gouvernement il y a pas
de majorité nationale vote la motion de
censure des insoumis qui eux-mêmes ont
mis le bazar pendant x semaines à la
soirée
mais il faudrait les voies des
républicains je sais que ça a touché
Adrien vous savez nos électeurs nous
connaissent bien ils nous ont dit mais
vous avez vu le spectacle que vous allez
donner vous êtes tous concernés par ce
que vous avez fait ça n'est pas bien moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on sorte moi déjà de
ce plateau avec un engagement que c'est
bazar que l'on vient d'assister ça
s'arrête parce qu'on ne peut pas compter
49-3 là
moi je respecte les institutions vous
condamnez la Constitution vous voulez la
changer si un jour vous êtes au pouvoir
vous pouvez le faire et j'ai pas de
souci si vous parlez du référendum
révocatoire tout cela moi je voulais
vous avez le choix des armes
actuellement il y a une constitution qui
s'applique à chacun ce que je voudrais
dire c'est qu'il faut qu'on respecte les
institutions lorsqu'on respecte pas un
ministre un premier ministre la
président de la République un
parlementaire un journaliste je pense
quelque part on affaiblit la République
moi je suis quelqu'un qui est attaché à
la républicain pur produit de la
République de l'école de cette
république qui m'a tant donné c'est pour
ça que je m'investis à fond pour cette
république et je crois qu'il y a un
problème de comportement qu'on doit
faire évoluer les uns et les autres et
vous êtes dessus avec lesquels je pense
qu'on peut trouver ce chemin pour faire
évoluer ce comportement qui vous dessert
qui desserte qui dessert la démocratie
qui nous dessert qui nous sert tous
parce qu'on doit être efficace on a des
enjeux considérables c'est-à-dire
l'Ukraine elle est là la fierté de la
vie je pense qu'on l'un et l'autre on
sait ce que c'est et les gens ils sont
très très inquiets sur ces questions là
donc il y a des sujets qui exigent à un
moment ou un autre bien sûr projet
contre-projet on sera pas adhérents de
la même famille politique l'un et
l'autre même si disons-le parfois
on peut avoir loyer c'est m'entretien
que passer les effets de tribune passer
les effets de tribus il y a des choses
sur lesquelles on doit avoir une
intelligence collective j'en appelle un
sursaut d'intelligence collective